I love this idea that our senses aren't
capable of perceiving all and there's a
beautiful humility in that and it
reminded me of your conversation with
David Lynch I was listening to that
conversation on your podcast and he said
something very interesting in trying to
describe consciousness and we have this
sense that what is real is the
three-dimensional things in our in our
purview what we can touch what we can
sense what we can hear but in truth it
is only consciousness that is real
because everything that exists in this
material realm is but a projection of
that consciousness so no take this and
run with it for a mows your next
beautiful monologue to come out of this
well cuz I agreed with you quite early
on I'd must admit I did start thinking
about the chocolate raisins that were
left on the bed in the room I was in so
a little bottle of chocolate raisins man
they're [ __ ] delicious the white
elephant they know how to do a chocolate
raisin rich I'm telling ya is it vegan
there was milk chocolate ones they were
what don't tell me I've had a theory
that's why smack it and you're gonna do
me for lactose I I'm so invested in your
vegan journey Russell it's so
disappointed I didn't ask if they was
vegan I was lonely I was in a hotel room
I was triggered
you're lucky that you didn't come out of
the window with success I don't deserve
to be happy
I don't know where to go from here don't
you go anywhere
you stay here which role you beautiful
man you come on you don't need any more
information on limitlessness of
consciousness and the fact that the
senses are just instruments for
detecting particular frequencies of data
and it'll be a coincidence wouldn't it
if the instruments for detecting data
that we had were the only instruments
for detecting data that were feasible in
infinity oh yeah it just turns out that
human beings have got the five
instruments through which all data can
be received even though we know already
that we can only see a limited light
range only here a particular sound range
there's even mammals on the planet can
see and hear things that we don't see in
here isn't it likely then that there are
different frequencies new realms
distinct forms of data that we don't
have the instruments to receive but that
don't mean they're out there that's the
particular kind of materialistic
ignorance that determined that could be
klein of our species if none of us here
at a sense of smell not me not you not
none of us how would we understand the
concept of a sense of smell babe the
smell of paint the smell of bacon not
that you'd like that you're gorgeous
vegan you'd be better off meat in that
paint no Richie Rich makes good food
I've eaten that cheating I know it's not
mine
give Julia the credit for props to Julie
she seems like a woman not to mess
around with on the vegan subject I mean
all week is a pretty serious RNA they're
always ready to give you a good thump if
you undermine their food my point is
this massive jaw to criticise require
I'm a vegan okay I just had a little
relapse upstairs Jesus Christ believe me
in 2006 other than a lot worse things
with em chocolate raisins
I wouldn't be milling in my mouth let me
tell you it's likely I think that there
are forms of information frequencies
that are inaccessible to us due to the
material limitations of being in evolved
ape and if you don't know that then like
I recommend some psychedelic experiences
which will introduce you to the
limitations of human consciousness the
fact that your individuality is a
construct arrived from the biochemistry
of the anatomy and and memory and
suddenly to be introduced to the
infinite particularly like when I did it
when I was like 14 with no proper
guidance so confused a bus-stop it's a
difficult place to meet god and the bus
was still late England so what does God
look like for you God looks like the
thing that's doing the looking sometimes
when I'm talking to atheists I think
what do you think you are experiencing
where are you talking to me from don't
you think it's mysterious that you're
here in a body experiencing reality
alive this is my life who says where did
you get that idea in my life my life we
are alive we are conscious we are awake
and I believe like our mutual friend
David Lynch that behind all separation
is oneness that more will be revealed
that apocryphally and anecdotally the
reason that heroism seems so beautiful
you hear some tale of a woman leaps out
of a moving vehicle to rescue a stranger
and you feel Wow because in this moment
we recognize that yes oneness truth
sacrifice principles that seem now
deeply embedded when we live in a time
where we're told that our job is to find
individual fulfillment through various
forms of consuming or the acquisition
of prestige or property these are
difficult ideas to overcome because
they're underwritten by biological
drives you know I'm not criticizing
people for falling for a global con but
corn is what it is it is a con that is
inescapable everywhere we turn it is
affirmed it's in our face this message
that we cannot escape that the
fulfillment the purpose the happiness
the connection that we seek will be
found in purchase it will be found in
status it will be found in the pursuit
of career advancement and material
accumulation and a surrounding of luxury
yeah that's right because of course
we're we have necessary appetites and
drives to eat and consume and procreate
and have status and achieve social power
and to be liked all of these drives are
present but these drives in my opinion
are not my opinion I've been told to
someone making this up Oprah listening
to other people these drives get
appropriated by cultural systems that
pose as neutral but are not neutral to
continue promote states of fear states
of difference it this is a deliberate it
not it necessarily in a Machiavellian
way but when people are in continual
state of fear fear induced by media
coverage of politics and global
geopolitical affairs this creates fear
fear induces an unconscious state I know
in me when I'm frightened I'm not
rational if you make me nervous and
afraid I can't think clearly
similarly when I'm flooded with desire
that other great unconscious state used
by the advertising and marketing
professions no offense if that's what
you do because all of us were all
participating you know like I didn't
come here today on a meal you know
although with the blanket you could be
forgiven thinking it's possible fear and
desire unconscious states states that
cause disconnection so I don't feel like
it's an individual problem or this
individual culpability and there's some
to scientific evidence now that we don't
even have the autonomy that we
previously perceived ourselves to have I
suppose the same way that if you require
breath to stay alive how his breath
external to you breath is another organ
we're continually in symbiosis and
osmosis with our environment even
through evolution even if you are the
most materialist rationalist person out
there and there's nothing wrong with
that some of my best friends are
materialists rationalists you know the
fact is is that we need one another we
need our environment we need love the
trend is pointing towards oneness
through our mythic history if there can
be such a thing as myth now I mean more
the history of myth throughout the
history of myths we see certain
archetypes and themes Universal
absolutes recurring I believe that these
could be regarded as a code a map to our
true nature a kind of pathway that we
can walk